ligne tirée la toile blanc de mes nuits
s'étir et je tire alors les lignes que
j'aligne à l'infini dans ce désert si
adore écrire des poèmes dans ces moments
de loisir intervient sur une radio
privée ou encore anime un café
philosophique tous les samedis soirs
mirose Mo caher est avant tout médiateur
familial un métier qu'elle est encore la
seule à exercer à la Réunion et qui
demande un savoir-faire en matière de
communication une grande capacité
d'écoute et de conseil pour pour
accompagner les couples en détresse et
qui vivent le drame de la rupture
familiale pourquoi avoir voulu faire ce
métier ah mais j'ai toujours été dans la
relation d'aide j'adore aider j'adore
apporter mon concours aux personnes qui
ont besoin de moi et avec les petits
moyens que j'ai j'essaie de d'entendre
Laur souffrance et de les accompagner
bien sûr et quelle formation il faut
avoir pour exercer ce métier c'est vrai
que moi je voulais être assistante
sociale depuis toujours je voulais être
assistante sociale et je pensais ça
allait me me
permettre d'aider les les les personnes
comme je je voulais le faire mais je
crois que j'ai fait un petit peu mieux
j'ai suivi après une formation j'ai eu
la chance de de de faire une formation
qui est accessible justement au monde
socio-juridique j'ai eu ce privilège
donc j'ai suivi cette formation longue
de 2 ans qui après sanctionné par un
diplôme délivré par l'Institut européen
de la médiation familiale et ça vous
donne le certificat d'aptitude à la
pratique de la médiation
familiale bonjour bonjour madame bonjour
entrez quand un couple se décide à venir
vous voir à quel stade de leur relation
ils sont ils peuvent être à n'importe
quel stade ils peuvent être dans un
stade où ils ne savent pas très bien ce
qu'ils vont faire où il ils ont le
sentiment de ne plus se comprendre de ne
plus s'entendre et il y a peut-être un
problème de communication là ils
viennent me voir si ça marche si on a
mis à plat les problèmes et qui pe ils
se rendent compte qu'ils peuvent
continuer et ben ils continuent sinon ma
fois on envisage les solutions les plus
satisfaisantes et pour eux et pour les
enfants bien sûr dans le l'éventualité
d'une rupture comment vous abordez les
problèmes de de couple avec des
enfants les enfants les enfants c'est
extrêmement compliqué de les faire venir
en médiation et surtout très délicat
j'avoue qu'au début de ma profession
j'étais assez réticente pour les faire
venir en médiation je me disais que je
vais encore les traumatiser je vais
encore les perturber euh c'est
extrêmement difficile et j'ai réfléchi
après je me suis dit ils ont besoin
d'entendre ce qui va se passer surtout
que ça les concerne eux ils sont en
premier chef concernés par cette
situation avec mes mots tout simplement
mais évidemment on va pas les faire
venir à n'importe quel moment de la
médiation il faut attendre que le
conflit soit vraiment désamorcé que la
passion euh soit au plus bas que les les
émotions soient vraiment au plus bas
pour que les parents puissent me les
amener pour qu'ils puissent comprendre
eux-mêmes qu'il est important que les
enfants soient au courant de ce qui se
passe et puis après ma fois il faut
aussi les entendre en ce sens qui sont
concernés et on oublie trop souvent que
les enfants aussi ont eux aussi leur mot
à dire même s'ils n'ont pas pouvoir ir
de décision mais au moins qu'ils
entendent qu'il donnent leur avis qu'il
ne fassent pas de choix bien sûr c'est
extrêmement difficile de demander à un
enfant de choisir d'abord il n'est pas
question de de demander à un enfant de
choisir il aime ses parents tous les
deux il aime son père et sa mère de la
même façon mais il faut l'assurer de cet
amour là aussi de ces parents qui vont
qui vont toujours l'aimer tout le temps
parce qu'ils ne divorcent pas avec leurs
enfants bien sûr et les enfants ne
divorcent pas avec leur en général qui
fait la démarche la femme ou l'homme euh
statistiquement parlant on aurait plutôt
tendance à dire que c'est les femmes qui
viennent en général les premières mais
il arrive aussi que les hommes se
décident à venir alors surtout
lorsqu'ils ont le sentiment qu'il faut
faire quelque chose qu'il faut sauver le
couple les les hommes lâchent beaucoup
moins facilement que les femmes j'ai le
sentiment ça n'engage que moi oui les
hommes tiennent quand même même au
couple quoi qu'on en dise oui oui ça
c'est révélateur oui oui ouion a
tendance à croire le contraire non tant
mieux disons qu'on va dire que les
femmes sont beaucoup moins indulgentes
elles sont moins tolérantes elles
tranchent beaucoup plus facilement euh
elles auraient plutôt tendance à à à en
finir et tout de suite les hommes au
contraire s'accrochent enfin en ce qui
me concerne c'est le constat que je fais
il y a beaucoup de de de préjugés
d'idées reçues euh c'est comme on dit
c'est les femes par
ex souffr davantage et tout non moi je
vois des hommes aussi en Lambo hein je
dois aussi ramasser des hommes à la
cuillère je pense que c'est important de
le savoir il faut le savoir il souffr
aussi mais disons qu'il souffrent
différemment ils vont essayer de garder
cette souffrance par de vers eux ils
vont essayer de faire ce qu'ils peuvent
faire et là ils vont donner une image
qui n'est pas forcément conforme à à ce
qui sont réellement euh ils veulent pas
faire mentir leur réputation de macho
d'hommes viril et tout en fait ce sont
des hommes qui souffrent tout autant que
les femmes il ne faut pas généraliser je
pense qu'il faut faire attention c'est
comme les pères on a toujours pensé que
les hommes n'étaient pas capables
d'aimer leurs enfants moi je suis
peut-être une des rares femmes qui me
bat auprès des hommes auprès des pères
pour qu'ils aient aussi la possibilité
de s'occuper de leurs enfants tout
exactement comme les femmes on a on leur
a pas donné l'occasion peut-être de
s'occuper de leurs enfants sont capables
oui j'en suis intimement convaincu par
expérience vous auriez préféré
intervenir à quel moment des problèmes
du couple mais j'aurais souhaité euh
intervenir dans le préventif bien sûr
hein lorsqu'un couple ne va pas bien
lorsqu'il sent qu'il y a quelque chose
qui ne va pas il serait bon qu'on voille
un professionnel de la communication
pour rétablir la le dialogue la
communication faire en sorte que ça
aille mieux plutôt que d'avoir après à
soigner les les les blessures qui sont
parfois très très profondes d'où la
nécessité de travailler en réseau je ne
suis pas seule je crois que ce métier il
faut le faire aussi en toute humilité
c'est-à-dire connaître ces limites et
nous avons tendance tout un chacun
d'oublier que nous avons des limite
aussi je dis toujours que nous sommes
compétents dans certains domaines mais
nous ne sommes pas polyvalents c'est
dire que lorsqu'il y a une trop grande
souffrance je je n'essaie pas de la
soigner seule je passe le relay à des
professionnels du monde médical ou à
d'autres personnes qui peuvent relayer
et puis après je reprends les personnes
en médiation une fois que la le deuil
est fait totalement il y a des personnes
qui sont compétentes pour m'aider c'est
une profession libéral est-ce que il y a
un côté associatif aussi dans ce métier
bien sûr heureusement je n'ai pas pensé
qu'à des personnes qui pourrai prétendre
à mes prestation j'ai aussi pensé à des
personnes dont les ressources ne sont
pas élevées ne peuvent pas prétendre au
Pr ition de médiateur familial donc il y
a une association qui s'appelle la
médiation familiale dans l'océan Indien
mfoi pour laquelle je travail je suis la
prestataire de service de cette
association et ça permet aux personnes
au revenus modestes d'avoir accès aussi
au à la médiation familiale et c'est
tant mieux quels sont les avantages de
ce métier pour moi cette profession n'a
que des avantages bien sûr parce que
déjà elle permet aux gens de de
s'entendre d'entendre leur souffrance
mutuelle chose qu'ils ne font jamais qui
n'ont pas la possibilité de le faire
bien sûr parce qu'elles ne sont pas
accompagné ces personneslà donc à mon
avis ça contient l'angoisse ça contient
ça régule les émotions ça permet d'avoir
au moins une structure où ils vont
pouvoir être écoutés où ils vont pouvoir
se dire ce qu'ils ont à se dire et puis
voir enfin si c'est possible de se
projeter dans l'avenir peut-être plus en
tant que mari femme ou compagnon mais au
moins parents ça ça me semble
indispensable qu'on reste parent ça doit
absolument durer perdurer et ne jamais
mourir le parental parce que nos enfants
quel que soit leur âge restent nos
enfants et ils ont besoin de nous ils
ont absolument besoin de nous est-ce que
vous n'avez pas tendance à trop prendre
sur vous est-ce que vous arrivez à vous
protéger oui je c'est vrai que je
m'expose beaucoup dans ce métier mais je
je pense
pouvoir me protéger j'essaie de le faire
mais j'y arrive je crois je ça fait des
loisirs oui bien sûr j'adore écrire
j'adore danser j'adore chanter j'adore
rire j'aime la vie je suis profondément
amoureuse de la vie et c'est ce qui va
me permettre justement d'aller jusqu'au
bout vous avez voulu un décor spécial
pour accueillir les gens à votre bureau
pourquoi c'est le et ben c'est moi ce
que vous voyez ici c'est moi là à la
Plaine des Palmistes ce sera pareil où
je suis chez moi c'est au milieu de
poupée au milieu de douceur au milieu de
choses Ben qui qui apaisent mais c'est
tout à fait moi quoi je veux dire il y a
pas un décor qui a été fait qui a été
monté spécialement pour le métier c'est
tout simplement mirose chez elle là où
elle est maître même si elle n'est pas
dans son bureau elle est chez elle
partout c'est c'est chez moi tout
simplement et quand vous voulez changer
de cadre c'est à la plaine que ça se
passe c'est à la plain des Palmistes oui
euh par exemple à la maison des
tourelles où j'ai passé mon enfance où
je me suis occupée d'enfants parce qu'il
faut savoir que j'aime beaucoup les
enfants et mon combat c'est surtout de
les rendre un peu moins malheureux après
autant d'années de métier quel conseil
vous pouvez donner aux familles bah
d'essayer de de de se parler surtout à
une époque où on communique
semble-t-il beaucoup moi personnellement
je dois dire que les gens ne
communiquent plus ne savent plus dire
qu' s'aiment encore qui tiennent l'un à
l'autre ça c'est important que les gens
se disent qu'il s'aiment et si il y a
autant de rupture à mon avis c'est parce
qu'on ne se dit plus les choses qu'on a
envie de se dire par pudeur ou par par
manque de temps ou par peut-être je ne
sais pas je n'ai pas la réponse mais je
sais que les gens ne savent plus se dire
qu'il s'aiment pour vous le dialogue est
très important dans un couple essentiel
ou on devrait être vigilant lorsqu'on a
commence à se dire mais j'ai plus rien à
lui dire c'est qu'on a encore des tas de
choses à lui dire mais il faut vite les
lui dire vite les lui dire avant que ça
bascule justement je suis épuisée
j'essaie d'entrevoir des signes qui
clignent le jour sortira-t-il enfin de
l'infini si un matin apparaît je tire un
dernier trait de ligne pour étouffer les
étincelles de mes nuits et puis avec la
jolie poussière d'étoile je signe les
secrets de ma mémoire pour un temps
endormi